[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him I mean it's no
charges counts of federal indictments I
mean it's not
91 but he's up to what 11 now 12 12
felony counts or I mean I charges not
felony counts I think he's got I think
he's got three felonies now
so Hunter Biden is edging
on on the verge of getting close to the
amount of federal indictments that
Donald Trump says MAA should love him at
this point do you remember now I'm old
enough to remember this I'm old enough
to Remember When Donald Trump stood on
stage with the email lady do you
remember the email lady they don't even
talk about the email lady anymore
they're not like emails emails emails
they're like truck payments truck
payments truck payments truck payments
truck payments
down payments on trucks it's bribery
it's corruption that's what they're
saying now it's no more about the
emails um but I remember I'm old enough
to remember Grandpa poopy pants standing
on stage with the email lady and he me
being challenged about not paying
taxes like him being challenged about
not paying taxes and he was like that
makes me smart and they were like yeah
it makes him smart to cheat on his
taxes I think now they're like lock
Conor Biden up lock him up for cheating
on his taxes and then admitting that he
cheated on his taxes and paying the the
[__] tax shouldn't that be the
[__] penalty of not paying your taxes
is to pay the taxes plus the the
penalties that Hunter Biden's paid in
most of these cases now again you want
to talk about [__] politic political
prosecutions here holy [__]
holy
[__] I mean their best case for these
felony charges against H Biden and I I'm
not I'm not gonna lie I think this is
all [__] like I mean are we are we
really gonna go around the country
locking people up for cheating on their
taxes I mean how [__] many prisons
are you gonna want to
build I don't know I don't know if most
people don't know this but our tax
reporting system is voluntary I know
that feels weird to say that at first
you are required to pay taxes on your
income in this country you're required
to do it if you don't you could suffer
consequences sometimes criminal
consequences now the best case that it
appears that they have that Hunter Biden
was committing fra tax fraud which I
believe to some level he probably was
meaning he knew he had to pay the taxes
he just used it for hookers and blow
instead de like that's probably the best
case they've got against him right in a
courtroom but the guy is already paid
the taxes plus the penalties so I think
this is going to fall on jury's deaf
ears he might catch one felony count
maybe two in a court with a jury almost
all these misdemeanors aren't going to
amount to [__] at this point and why the
[__] is a special
Council running around the country a
special Council folks
David Weiss now has special counsel um
privileges that's why he's able to
charge him in
California okay now I'm not upset the
hunter Biden's charge I don't give a
[__] I will never vote for Hunter Biden
I don't know if anyone if any if you
manga idiots need to know I will never
cast a ballot for Hunter Biden stupid
bastards but the problem with this whole
narrative around Hunter Biden is that we
should defend him and you know I'm I'm
I'm not here to defend Hunter Biden I'm
here to look objectively at the charges
that they've charged him with and what
they're claiming in the house [__]
oversight committee that they're going
to impeach Hunter Biden because that
seems to be what they want to do is
impeach Hunter Biden from an elected
office that he does not [__] hold
Jesus [__] Christ but wouldn't you
believe that if they were going to go as
far to charge him with the tax the the
tax crimes and the tax fraud that they
were going to give him what the
Republicans called The Sweetheart deal
for in California don't you think they
would have dug up a little bribery don't
you think they would have dug up some
[__] felony counts against the far a
the far the
Foreign Relations
Act don't you think don't you [__]
think they would have come up with some
money laundering charges don't you think
instead of him not just paying taxes and
using it to buy hookers and blow
that's literally that's literally the
case that they're making is Hunter Biden
didn't pay his taxes because he was
spending that money on [__] drugs and
[__] and
[__] shouldn't shouldn't MAA love this
guy I mean that's that's what I'm kind
of confused about here if you want to
know the God's honest truth this guy's
got a ton of porn on his laptop
apparently he's buying he's spending all
kinds of money running around acting
like he's a [__]
billionaire in in lavish houses
travel he's joining Sex Private sex
clubs and [__] you know Jeffrey Epstein
style Donald
Trump he's joining golf courses he's
coercing accountants to change his
accounting to [__] cook the books
which I mean there's a guy on trial in
New York right now for doing that [__]
cooking the books to make it look like
you're richer than you are and deducting
I don't know if you know this but the
Trump organization was [__] found
guilty of criminal charges in the state
of New
York for [__] using
Apartments to evade taxes to pay
employees bonuses
[__] this is the dumbest [__]
I've ever seen in my life that MAA
doesn't like Hunter
Biden honestly MAA should want Hunter
Biden to run against Joe Biden at this
point they [__] should love Hunter
Biden have you seen have you seen
pictures from a [__] party at Mar
Lago have you seen these pictures Hunter
Biden would fit in there
perfectly perfectly he'd fit in there
with the looks of it
get the [__] out of here with this
[__] somehow somehow MAA hates
Hunter
Biden they love Hunter Biden they love
that he that and and this idea that
somehow he's Joe Biden's Kryptonite or
something that somehow this is going to
undermine Joe Biden's
election and they can't they can't stop
with the non
which I'm all here for it really
honestly and Hunter Biden getting
charged with three felony counts of tax
fraud when their mango musolini Jesus
stands on stage and is bragging hell he
standing in front of a courtroom talking
about how it's legal for him to evade
taxes and to lie about what what things
are worth all the while lying about what
things are worth it's crazy [__] [__]
we live in a [__] just a crazy stupid
timeline it's the dumbest it's the
dumbest like we this is the best time in
history
folks I don't know if You' noticed but
technology is advancing every single
[__] 10
seconds 10 years from now I don't even
know that we could predict how far
technology is going to
go better worse or indifferent
we're like in the Golden Age of humanity
here and we're talking about the dumbest
[__] [__] ever we're having to have
the dumbest conversations aren't we it's
just the stupidest [__] [__] I've
ever
seen and it feels like it's getting
worse not
better when you have a a a a United
States Attorney who ask for special
counsel
privileges from the attorney general and
from doj so they can charge Hunter Biden
the president's
son of T three felony tax fraud charges
of the taxes that he's paid back plus
the
penalties are you [__] kidding me
this guy didn't try to steal elections
folks he didn't commit fraud he wasn't
[__] intimidating election
workers and getting their getting his
cult members to intimidate election
workers he wasn't doing that he he
wasn't coercing fake electors in the
states of Michigan Georgia and Arizona I
don't know if you heard that that's a
piece of news all excuse me Nevada
Arizona 2 and Pennsylvania I've been
telling you for a long time there's
going to be charges in Michigan Nevada
Arizona Pennsylvania and probably
Wisconsin including Georgia
and here we go now Georgia Michigan and
now we've got them in Nevada the funny
part is is that they weren't they were
cing out in the open all these fake
electors that have now been charged in
the state of
Nevada we're all standing in a picture
that the that the official party the
official GOP put on their Twitter
account they posted a video of them
cing
right out in the
open they're salivating for a dictator
and it's clear on
that but they should love Hunter Biden
shouldn't they they really should I feel
like I feel like they're missing the
Mark here their hatred for Hunter Biden
is just the exact opposite of how they
should feel about this
guy and maybe it's because he's you know
he went to rehab and cleaned his act up
and maybe he's not on as many drugs drug
and he's not doing as many hookers and
[__] like that anymore and he kind of
blew all his [__]
money
right and maybe that's why they [__]
hate him because he's a
reformed reformed guy right they don't
like that he found Jesus type [__] and
they definitely don't like when you find
I mean they want to talk about
Jesus they want to pretend they're
Christians right but they don't want to
actually do the things and follow the
gospel right nah [__] no don't want to
do that and when you do point that out
that really [__] triggers them when
you point out that they're not actual
Christians that they're just calling
themselves Christians but what they are
is white Christian nationalists they're
Nazis and I'm sick of that too the
internet calling them Christian
nationalist they're not Christian
nationalists they're white Christian
nationalists I wish they get it right
I I mean I know it's going to get there
next year and people are going to follow
my lead on this because that it seems
they always [__] do because I'm the
only one that's willing to go out on a
limb and just tell you the whole [__]
truth when it happens instead of just
[__] footing around about it until
about three four six months
later it's white Christian nationalism
I've been calling it white Christian
nationalism for a long [__] time
white Christian nationalism it is not
just Christian nationalism that is the
[__]
threat why do you think they're as
someone says in the Discord here
salivating for a dictator I mean
dictator we were talking about this in
the morning producers meeting over on
Discord now if you want to participate
in the in the producers Corner go join
the $20 dis Discord or patreon here and
you can get in the Discord and you can
come join our morning meetings an hour
before the show it's a really great
conversation it's not like the show it's
a conversation between all the people in
The Producers Corner we talk about all
kinds of issues but this morning we were
talking about um Donald Trump wanting to
be a dictator and the right-wing media
really trying to handle this and it's
really kind of funny and the reason why
it's so important is because of this
project 2025 stuff that's coming and and
what I mean by coming is they're going
to be jerking off the project 2025 and
running on it so it it coming is a good
is a good [__] word for
it oh they're gonna they can't wait to
run on 2025 they're already laying the
groundwork I showed you that this
week and uh Nats girl brought up in the
producers Corner today is don't you
think that Trump is just getting off on
this dictator talk and he absolutely is
oh my God he's got such a [__] [__]
chub for his cult to want him to be the
dictor I mean
dictator right oh man he he can't wait
because he's always been in love with
authoritarians oh yeah they could just
murder anyone they want he can they can
oppress anyone they want he they can
shut up anyone who dissents like oh my
God there's no there's no better [__]
figure that Donald Trump loves an
authoritarian dick taster right I mean
dick aters excuse me I keep keep having
it slip out my
mouth oh
boy but yes he's excited about his
cult wanting him to be an authoritarian
and he can't wait for his cult to like
confirm it and they're getting there
like it's a slow walk to it because this
is how you get to this point like Hitler
Hitler didn't say I'm a Nazi and then
I'm going to take over Germany and then
he was the he was the furer that's not
how it happened not at all and and if
you want to go back and look at the
history Hitler was elected
Folks by slim margins but he was
elected and that's when he got elected
that's when he took over you know like
he was only a dictator on day one and it
just so happened that it worked out and
everyone loved it because that's truly
where they're slow walking to is that
they're going to be telling you and I
know I've said this when he said it that
day but it is going to get to the point
to where they are saying yes we want him
to be the dictator like they're gonna
say it out loud they're gonna be saying
this [__] to you like what are you
talking about what are you are you
insane like no we're just we're [__]
brainwashed into this [__] and it's
fantastic but he can't wait for the day
that his cult confirms that they want
him to be a dictator because he wants to
be
one and they're working at they're
getting there it's again it's a it's a
process that they got to do to really
[__] get their their sheep fat enough
to admit that they wanted to be a
dictator but they're gonna feed him
enough food of this sheep food now you
see it in the rightwing media where
they're like um they're like we know we
we know you've you are a Nazi but don't
be convinced when the media says you're
a Nazi right and that's the talk now and
they can't they can't help themselves
because the narrative is piling on top
of them because it's a reality it's a
reality that Trump wants to be an
authoritarian
figure I mean there's there's you can't
ignore this fact and they're not going
to be able to ignore it
either that's what I'm telling you and
and some people you know believe that
project 2025 is dangerous and and scary
and we should be afraid of it well the
dangerous part has already happened with
project 202 and I know that that feels
weird that oh well Tony if it's
implemented yeah but that that we stand
in its way okay the pro-democracy
Coalition of people believe in democracy
in this country standing its [__] way
period and there ain't a goddamn thing
they can do about that at this point I
mean they want to that's why they want
to implement project 2025 but it's too
late for them they've already lost this
war of democracy vers autocracy they
really have their ideas aren't with
winning
folks they're not winning and they're
not going to win as long as we do our
job and our job is to democracy it's to
engage in
it and our battle is at The Ballot Box
That's Where It's At they want us to
battle other places but the battle is at
The Ballot
Box and that's where it's going to
happen but this project 2025 stuff the
dangerous part has already happened
they've let the cat out of the
bag they can't undo the fact that
they've said this is what they want
because you have to remember who is
talking about this project 2025 and more
importantly who developed this project
2025 because this hearkens back decades
and decades and decades even even in in
Germany before Hitler was even an idea
that he would be a fear her but I mean
that Mighty librarian brought up a good
point in the in the producers corner
this morning that Ronald Reagan imp
tried to implement a lot of this back in
the
80s so they've been they've been working
to this point for a long time but the
cat is out of the bag now where the
entire apparatus of the Republican party
and all their think tanks and all that
[__] the trash fascist that are over
on the right have finally got together
and said you know what we're just going
to say the quiet part out loud because
apparently the [__] the dict tast or
cult loves
it so we're just going to say the quiet
part out loud we want this to be a
fascist State and we want
authoritarianism because that's truly
what project 2025 lays out is
authoritarianism and at no better time
too folks it and again I I know it feels
like I'm saying are you supporting
project 2025 I am absolutely supporting
for the Republican party to embrace
project 2025 yes absolutely Donald
Trump's going to embrace it he already
has I mean Steve Bannon was really
pissed off the other day that that Sean
Hannity let let Donald Trump say the
quiet part out loud too
soon but this is what they do this is
what the FAS does to these people they
can't help themselves when the fascism
really takes hold they wet their pants
for this
stuff
that's what I've been trying to point
out to you for years and years and years
and years and yes the media finally
catches up with me to some degree I mean
they're they're still talking about
MSNBC on MSNBC about how Donald Trump's
a
fascist oh really you're just now
figuring that out oh my well welcome to
the [__] party
friends the Atlantic wrote a big article
about how Donald Trump will be an
authoritarian figure will be what the
[__] are you talking about
man he was his entire presidency was him
trying to figure out how to be a
dictator and when they wouldn't let him
he tried to force them and commit a coup
to let him be the dictator you dumb
[__] what are you talking
about almost every single [__] scummy
ass authoritarian type executive order
was stricken down by the
courts Democrats stood in his way the
Deep State the administrative
bureaucracy stood in his way because he
wanted [__] to be done that was illegal
and the reason why it's illegal isn't
because it's crime it's because our
government is a democratic
constitutional republic and there's a
constitution a law that stood in his way
of being an
authoritarian and they can't help but
say out loud that they want to undermine
that that they'll do anything anything
to undermine that that that premise of
our democracy that Foundation of our
democracy that's why we as the
pro-democracy Coalition should not
attack the foundation we should not
attack the institution of democracy even
if we think it's what's best for it
that's a that's a bunch of
[__] undermining the institutions
and the foundation of our democracy in
the name of democracy is not saving our
democracy it's not
period and it'll bear out that way you
just wait [__] doubt me doubt me
it'll play out that way and you won't
like it
so stay focused on what's important and
what's important here is that us as the
pro-democracy Coalition do what we do
best and that is
democracy that's engaging in the ballot
that's making sure that we stand in the
way of these fascists taking over large
swaths of our
government and undermining our
constitution by trying to frame up this
country into some sort a fascist
authoritarian
State and the more they dig in and the
more they say the Qui out part the
better the better folks there is there
is a large percentage of the population
in this country that has not woke up to
the fact that Republicans and the Maga
cult want a
dictator they want it they want an
authoritarian they want someone to go
after their enemies
that's what they want these white
Christian nationalists want that and
there's a part of the country that
hasn't woken up to that [__] reality
yet but the more they say this [__] out
loud the more they they Embrace project
2025 the plan for American
authoritarianism because that's what it
is the project 2025 is the plan for
American
authoritarianism and that's the choice
that we have next
year it's not someone's age it's not
who's been better in office it ain't the
[__]
economy it's democracy versus autocracy
and they're going to make it that
decision not
us we've already chosen democracy and
keep choosing
democracy that's what this is even
though the [__] eaters don't understand
that a constitutional republic is a form
of democracy they'll never get that I'm
going to show you some crazy [__] today
that would make me believe that the [__]
eaters should hate Donald Trump but you
know their cognitive dissonance gets in
the [__]
way but folks we have to stay focused on
this prize and the prize is is to show
the rest of the country not the sheet
eaters you're never going to convince
these [__] boneheads that they're
delusional it's going to take time for
them to realize they're delusional and
it may never it may never get to that
point for them to wake the [__] up I'm
talking about maanga but there is a
certain part of the country that isn't
paying attention and we got to get them
to pay attention we just got to keep
screaming yelling and pointing at it and
the rightwing is doing a perfect job for
us they're doing it they're saying it
out loud they're making it known all you
got to do is point it
out and I'm very confident I'm very
optimistic that this country country is
going to choose democracy because their
[__]
lifestyle their way of life depends on
Democracy so just hang tight do the
work and watch this show every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for two
full hours it's Friday December 8th I've
got a great G guest coming at you clip
is back that's right we have Glick cheor
here he's going to be joining us at the
bottom of the hour and and we got bone
end of the week because it's Friday so
the guy with the last name Sanchez is
going to be here and we're going to talk
about these Bon heads of the week but I
want to thank everyone who has ordered
the tattoo merch collection you have a
few more days a few more days to order
tattoo merch collection uh and get it by
Christmas if you want to give it as a
Christmas gift that's right you have a
few more days to order just go to the
Tony michaels.com that thony
michaels.com all you got to do is just
pan on down now hit the Subscribe button
at the top first but pan on down to the
tattoo merch collection you can use the
promo code holiday 10 that's right the
promo code holiday 10 that's holiday in
all caps one Z holiday in all caps one Z
and you get 10% off your entire order of
the tattoo merch collection so go to the
Tony michaels.com click on the tattoo
merch collection and you will be able to
use the promo code holiday 10 it's all
caps holiday 10 Z and you get 10% off
your order if you order by the 10th this
is why I did 10 if you order by the 10th
you should receive your holiday order in
time to give it as a Christmas gift so I
appreciate all the support all the shots
all the vimo chat I appreciate everyone
showing up this morning at the patreon
producers Corner as they always do on
Mondays and Fridays an hour before the
show and don't go anywhere we got a
great guest Cliff's coming at you
everyone loves when Cliffs on the show
so don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy there's Tammy by the time we
reach DC weight was F 50 strong in
number some patriots ran out of gas
along the way we got plenty of slim gems
and
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again here's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Doritos you like the red bag not the
live L and blue one and you're at since
I discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and I a even seen my
cousin Brody in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours
tamy [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast
welcome back to the show great guest
coming at as always he's usually here on
Thursdays but it's a different week so
we got him on Friday glad to have him
here on the show this week of course you
know I'm talking about clip Sher is here
welome to the party pal welcome to the
party
pal I really I saw a
u a true social a fraud social post
um from Grandpa poopy pants this morning
the the authoritarian dictator well he's
a day one dictator a dictator excuse me
I keep I don't know why I keep having
that slip that
he wants to have an
authoritarian uh member in his mouth um
but the grandpa boopy pants had a a
fraud social post this morning and this
is I really wanted to ask Cliff about
this when I saw this I was like a I'm
glad to have cliff on this morning so I
talked to about this so clip good
morning my friend or afternoon depending
on where you're at in the country I
guess it's afternoon I don't know where
the hell I am but I'm on your show
that's that's right that's right that's
right welcome welcome back my friend how
are you I'm doing great doing better
once I started listening to all the fun
stuff you were saying oh yeah well I I'm
always with the fun stuff I'm always
with the speaking of fun stuff this
morning so I I know you probably get
this a lot because I get this a lot too
like when I post shorts or are here on
the show or they you know these [__]
eaters in my comments section they're
always like this ain't a democracy it's
a republic like they say that all the
time right they say that all the time
and now it it would be nice if they took
the dictionary off the shelf and dusted
it off a bit and then like turned to the
definition of a constitutional republic
and actually read it a bit and
understand that yeah a republic doesn't
have to be a democracy but it can be and
in our case it is it is a democracy how
how how about that but you know what's
funny go ahead be good if they look back
at some of anything that was written by
the founders or anybody I mean they
probably look back at all the slave
holding parts and you know masturbate
with Glee but otherwise it'd be good if
they look back at parts that talked
about what we are that say right quite
clearly we are a Democratic Republic
that's the way that that was what we
were founded as and the reason they do
that that pernicious garbage is their
project 2025 in their agenda you know
colostomy bag I don't know what its
nickname is but that's right and
whatever the hell else they've come up
with they try to get rid of because
their project they're making it very
clear is to get rid of democracy right
and also democ democracy Democrat bad
word Republic Republican good word I
mean it's all branding garbage and
[__] you know that's that's and
that's what they're good at they're not
good at anything else well they're
they're definitely salivating over a
dictator I mean a dictator excuse me I I
don't know why keep I keep confusing
that word dictator for dict taster I I I
can't well may be burrito bow day over
there at maralago
and Donald Trump likes to try different
types of of of items in his his burrito
bowls he likes the large sausages
sometimes sometimes it'll be some
secrets we stole about an Iran nuclear
project that just gotten his food
somehow you never know what it might be
well it could be now here's here's the
thing though and we've noticed over the
last few days as the day one dict taster
um set it the quiet part out loud that
he wants to be a dictator on day one now
I know he kind of said it like only day
one but that's not how dictatorships
work it actually works like when you
become one you you stay one if you go
again if you dust off the dictionary and
look up the the meaning to the word
dictator you would know that that's what
that [__] means but you know who's
who's counting on what words
dictionar who's counting who who's
actually doing the math on how words
have definitions all you're reading and
learning and stuff right just stop it
here's the thing the crazy part about it
is that it's almost like when he said it
out loud because he really wants his
cult to want him to be a dictator right
he's waiting for this moment he's the
only one who can fix it as he said right
exactly but he's wanting his cult to say
it out loud he's wanting them to cheer
like at a rally be our fear her be our
fear her right like he's he's waiting
for this moment because he's got a huge
heart on for authoritarians we've always
known that and he want and it's because
he wants to be one and he figures his
maanga cult is going to shape him into
America's authoritarian but here's the
thing is that he let the cat out of the
bag a little too early because even
Steve bannon's like oh my God I'm so mad
at Sean Hannity for letting Donald Trump
say this out loud like Steve Bandon
isn't right Steve Bandon isn't like we
should get rid of trump because he wants
to be a dictator Steve Bandon is like oh
my God now everyone knows he wants to be
a dictator like that's what Steve
bannon's mad about and also my last to
my doctor my lipid count was way too
high and he told me that hygiene is
actually important oh really well I mean
I I think that's what Pro probably
probably but here's the thing here's the
thing that's crazy is kind of this that
because they're slow walking towards
them supporting a dictator openly like
we want a dictate this is what we want
it's a slow walk because they again I I
told the audience in the first 30
minutes Hitler didn't just be like I'm a
Nazi and now I'm the furer and then he
took control it took a slow walk and he
actually got elected believe it or not
uh in in
Germany right he was elected with a thin
margin because he broke up the country
not with a
majority a reminder right it makes me
think of another guy who can never win a
majority here right exactly but here's
the thinged to that position by the
conservatives which reminds you of other
things here the more traditional
conservatives they figured he'd bring
along the populist base and they could
control him sound like your life Mitch
mccon at all exactly exactly but here's
the thing is Donald Trump is now trying
to Brand because he realizes that it was
probably not a good thing that he did by
saying I want to be the dictator so soon
and what I mean by so soon is before he
has the nomination because once he has
the nomination then they can't really
stop him at that point um and that's
when they'll really salivate most them
will fall in line no matter how much
because they're pathetic that way right
and he is really confident that he's
going to win the nomination even if he
says this out loud which I'm very
confident he'll win the nomination even
saying this this soon out loud but
here's the problem here's what he
actually posted um on fraud social he
says here the Democrats disinformation
machine uh is hard at work trying to
sell the American public that Donald J
Trump president Donald J Trump which is
crazy so pathe yeah he is is a quote
threat to democracy no the only threat
to democracy is the incompetence and of
crooked Joe Biden we are now now a
failing Nation so the problem that I see
with this is that now he's in a
situation where he has to say no I'm not
the threat to democracy he is the
problem is is there his entire cult and
the entire and the entire idea of
authoritarianism is to undermine
democracy now he's saying out loud that
he wants democracy which is going to
cause a lot of confusion which I believe
is a good thing this is a good thing to
cause confusion amongst the masses
because what it does is it forces people
who really aren't paying attention to
have this conversation which when normal
people who are voters but do not pay
attention to politics start paying
attention to what is important in an
election authoritarianism versus
democracy is what our decision is going
to be next year when they pay attention
to that uh the sooner the better I guess
is where I'm going yeah well two key
things have happened here and probably
some others I'm not thinking of but I
can think of two things off the top of
my head one is because of people like
you and me and your audience and so many
other people out there that have kept
screaming and yelling about this and
losing our our Collective shite on the
media for the absolute piss poor job
that they've done during the entirety of
Trump's existence in politics finally
they started moving in the direction and
saying things the New York Times
actually used the FW and called them a
fascist The Washington Post actually had
an opinion piece about how it's likely
that we're going to become a
dictatorship now which I don't know that
I agree with but that's an important
piece for people to read and so some of
the main guys who determine in these big
newspapers and cable Outlets Joe
Scarboro had a whole long segment on it
you and I I think talked about this last
time this was these are very important
things but I'd say since last time the
other incredibly important thing and you
can hate her fine is Liz Cheney in the
end look I will argue with her all day
and all night long her policies are
wrong her policies are stupid uh you
know so don't think I'm sitting here
like oh she's wonderful now but would if
you read any of these books by experts
out there who tell you how
authoritarianism is defeated it is when
everybody else no matter their politics
from socialists on the left on over to
conservatives on the right unite against
either a communist on the left dictator
or a fascist dictator on the right so to
have her out there you know telling
these stories these behind the-scenes
stories and also undermining Mike
Johnson and Jim Jordan and all these
things she knows when she has the name
Cheney when she was in leadership when
her dad literally used to be the Satan
of the left and her dad was vice
president this is incredibly important
because she can reach again the 33% who
who are the cult members they're all in
there's nothing to do to change their
minds but what their game is here is
that other 15 to 20% whose votes they
can either suppress or who they can
convince that Donald Trump's the lesser
of two evils by making up garbage about
Hunter Biden and by impeach Biden and
trying to do everything they can to
muddy those Waters and that's why it's
really important that the media and that
Liz Cheney and people like her are out
there and I'm hoping that Cheney will
join Romney and will join you know
what's name kinzinger and other people
like that and go around the country and
make this argument to everybody so they
get it now Shannon here on YouTube is
pointing out because I actually disagree
a little bit more than just a little bit
with you on Cheney and here's the reason
why is I believe that Liz Cheney is
doing it for certain motivation which I
really don't give a [__] or motivation
um I don't care about her motivation I
know her motivation I I think that she's
going to try to run as a third-party
ticket that's the reason why I'm not I'm
not that I'm not advocating for Liz jany
to to to say uh or or for people to prop
her up as a hero now here's what I not a
hero remember I was very exactly no no
and here's here's what I want to say
about Liz Cheney I believe that um
you're correct in that this is the way
that fascism is beaten back but what is
important about Liz Cheney or Mitt
Romney or Adam
kininger especially Liz Cheney though is
that she was third in leadership in the
house caucus When Donald Trump was
trying to steal our election and commit
a coup she knew what was going on she's
admitted that she's been part of the
conversation the the part that bothers
me about Liz Cheney and I think this is
the conversation that all these
commentators should have because I think
it will force Liz Cheney to do what she
needs to do to get in a position where
her where her speaking out actually has
an effect because I actually think it
has it has no effect the way she's doing
it now because what she's not doing is
is she's not apologizing to America
because she caused Donald Trump she is
part of leadership she is part of the
apparatus which led to him
and same with Romney same with marowski
the same with all these ones who've
spoken out against him I agree
I just say something quickly though I
agree with you it's just I think that
there's Nuance here I think you're
playing as black and white as in either
she she makes a difference or she
doesn't I think she will be much more
effective if she apologizes and does and
does that kind of thing yes but I do
think they that still and I know some of
these people that are conservatives who
hate Trump or they still think they're
moderate Republicans I don't know what
that means anymore but and and those
types of folks can can deliver a message
to them people like Cheney and Romney
and rowy whatever that you and I cannot
deliver and so I do think again it's
I'll say quickly and I'll let you
respond to it it's not about making her
a hero because nope I just said
everything she believes that I know
about is stupid or wrong or both um and
it's not about pretending she had
nothing to do with this so did a bunch
of those never trumpers who are out
there doing stuff they were involved in
this stuff too but the pro but right now
when you're trying to bail you when your
whole purpose is stopping
authoritarianism I'm wor I'm willing to
work with almost anybody at the moment
and I'm willing to fight with them again
in the future I will not call them a
hero I will not whitewash what they did
in the past but they're saying this
stuff I still think has value and I
still think is important well I think
this conversation that we're having
right now is just important or more
important than it and the reason why is
because what I want to have happen is I
want Liz Cheney to move to apologize to
the country for what she did because
until she does all of it BS on deaf ears
and the reason why is because um um
because you talk about Nuance the
problem is in this country with social
media we've lost all Nuance we've lost
it we certainly lost most of it you're
absolutely we' lost we've lost a lot of
it and that's and and that's the reality
it's not it's not something that I want
but it is the reality um a prime example
is some of the [__] that has
happened with h and I want to talk to
you about this too real quickly if we
can is uh MIT I'm GNA talk about it with
you to you kick me off so
pen Penn University um and I think
Harvard went and testified and um the
situation where they're really they're I
I I [__] hate in this country that
people don't understand the First
Amendment they have the right to say
this [__] if they want but these
students don't have the right not to
have consequences and the consequences
when you call for genocide of Jewish
people is that you're going to lose your
your scholarships at the school that
you're saying that that's the
consequence no one's putting you in jail
but when you have the a private entity
that has the right and I'm sorry like I
I appreciate you're saying this I this
I'm involved in this conversation a I'm
Jewish and B um I went to University of
Pennsylvania so this is actually all
pretty important to me and it should be
the easiest thing I mean I what I what I
wanted to see there is look if I were to
go and I were to say something
horrendous like the n-word it would be
held against me and it should be held
against me because you're not going to
be jail but they're not going to put you
in jail but there will be consequences
there will be consequences has the right
to say we're a private institution
you're not saying that [__] on our
campus and it's the same thing when you
call for genocide of anybody you are
inciting violence whether you're calling
it for Jews or Armenians or whether
you're calling it for libyans or
Canadians you are inciting well not
Canadians because they're funny
but that that's that's okay when you
call for for any group of people you are
in citing violence and it should not be
allowed on that campus again it is
completely different the First Amendment
regulates what the government does these
schools go further and I know for a fact
that if I use certain kind of rhetoric
about certain groups of people they kick
my ass right out of there and they'd be
right to do it well and that's
consistent well and and the freedom of
speech does not exol you from
consequences it correct it it makes sure
that you can't be jailed and held
criminally responsible for using your
speech but it does and and I tell my
audience this and this is what I know
about the freedom of speech not what I
believe what I know is that every piece
of speech rather good bad indiff
whatever that piece of speech is there's
consequences consequences can be good
and they can be bad my view is is that
the consequence on these students doing
this is good that's a good consequence
it shows other people that hey be be
aware that when you use your freedom of
speech to call for other students on a
college campus to to to to be
exterminated to be exterminated that
you're going to have consequences that's
a good consequence to me it's bad in
their eyes and they're whining and
crying about the speech that they made
and the speech that they used and now
that there's consequences listen this is
manga type [__] when manga does this
stupid [__] when like you said they go
on TI raids inside of a [__]
restaurant and they're calling people
the nword or on a racist rant or doing
stupid [__] and then people are
recording it and they post it on the
internet and the internet it's like Hey
where's this person work oh this person
has public profiles and now we find out
who this person works and there's
consequences it's consequences folks
it's consequences your show here is a
private show you run it you make the
decisions if I go out there and I start
saying Tony Michaels that son of a [__]
is a racist you know you can say hey
Cliff's an [__] and I'm not having
him back on my show and you know what
you're not taking away my free speech
rights the government still guarantees
me that you're just saying I don't need
Cliff talking on my show the show that I
own well private institutions can make
those same decisions that we are not
going to allow this because this incites
violence it creates division among the
people here it leads to a hostile
environment on campus and it's wrong and
I'm sorry that whether you're playing
for genocide of Jews or whether you're
using certain loaded terms whether it's
for African-Americans or for some for
the lgbtq community we can make you know
others I can't go through and name every
group but the point is we can make these
determinations that no you can't be home
homophobic you can't be islamophobic
we're not going to let you do that on
campus and that's what this is about and
that and I want to Circle back to Liz
jany for a minute and that's all I'm
asking is that because Liz Cheney is
using her First Amendment right here
that's what she's doing she's using her
her her First Amendment right she's not
an elected member of Congress anymore um
she she's she's held to certain
standards about classified information
um because of laws surrounding that so
she doesn't have the First Amendment
right fully because the First Amendment
right isn't un isn't we have plenty of
exceptions you can threaten the
president's life you can't share child
porn which by the way I think that's a
good thing you may want to cut out but I
just said that because the YouTube
algorithm made oh no no I don't I I you
[__]
YouTube we we we we practice freedom of
speech here and we accept all the
consequences that's the that's the
difference but what I want to get back
to you is the consequences of Liz Cheney
speech and and the reason and I these
two things are not the same but the
freedom of speech is the same and that's
what I'm trying to say about Liz Cheney
is I'm not saying what she isn't doing
is good I'm saying the consequence of
her speech by her saying what she's
saying without the actual context that
hey the reason why I'm saying this is
because I know because I created this
because yeah I was there and if she
would say it that way and the me and the
thing that frustrates me the most is
she's on a book to her so she's she's
forcing whoever is interviewing her for
this book to not ask certain questions
that's how it works you you know this um
in media when you're doing certain tours
you want to make sure that certain
people aren't asking like she is you can
make rules about what they yes right and
and so what's frustrating to me is that
that is what is I know that's what is
happening and what's frustrating me is
Liz Cheney won't use her freedom of
speech to have the ultimate good
consequence which is what she says she
wants which is to to destroy Fascism and
and get back to the regular Republican
party right that's what she's saying um
but without her actually taking
responsibility and accountability in
public I believe that her speech that
she's using right now the consequence
badly is going to be that no one is
really gonna care what she says because
she's not doing the thing that she
should do that's my opinion I mostly
agree okay I mean I think I agree with
you she needs to apologize she needs to
make it clear she needs to make it clear
that that there are conse quences even
for her that she's learned things and
that she's changed okay like somebody
who's appropriate example you're talking
about right now I don't know whether you
like him or not but but Joe Walsh who
has come out and apologized numerous
times and said I was wrong I helped
create this I am I was the part of the
problem um I agree so I agree that that
that's something she and that and that
is that is a good example and I don't
mean to cut you off but that is a good
example I vly disagree with almost
everything Joe Walsh believes there's a
lot of [__] that me and him do not
connect on and we would never connect on
and and and he he he still has views and
he post them on online that he has those
views that I would vly disagree with but
I agree with you the fact that if Liz
Cheney did what Joe Walsh did she would
have more credibility with what she's
doing and and the reason why is because
it feels like to me most people are
viewing this the way I view it is that
Liz Cheney is trying to profit from a
book it's not really about democracy and
and it's kind of the [__] you pay
anything and and I I agree I the only
place we slightly disagree is I think
when she is saying it because of her
name and because of her former position
in the party and because of the
bankruptcy of our media that they love
big names and they want to quote
Republicans so they're getting both
sides you know and all of that is that
is that the media will report certain
things and say certain things they would
not say if she weren't saying them so I
still believe it hasn't in other words
the only place where you and I differ is
I I absolutely agree would have much
more of an impact if she would apologize
but I still believe it has some impact
and right now to me anything that stops
the orange Ghoul from crawling back into
our lives is something that I will
accept and I'm glad that we're having
this conversation I'm glad that we're
having this conversation because I think
what it does is it forces it forces the
the the the overall discourse into Liz
Cheney's uh Arena and her Universe to
say hey you're falling on death fears
you're you're not do it's not making
because I believe that she wants to make
an impact it's just she doesn't want to
go as far as she has to go to make that
impact she'll never make the impact
unless she does and and I the place I
disagree with you only other place
slightly is I don't think she's angling
for a third party run because I think
she's smart enough to look at the
numbers and like she can't win what I
think she's angling for is to try to to
to hobble the mag Maga side of that
party which I'm not sure is possible but
enough she's doing what Chris Christie
is doing they're both trying to set
themselves up for 2028 their hope is
defeat Trump you know and and and defeat
enough of the people like Trump that the
people that are pretending who aren't
real trumpers will come back and be more
like Liz Cheney or Chris Christie I'm
not sure that's possible I think it's
likely impossible so I think it's a
Fool's errand but as far as I'm
concerned the way same way I would say
Chris Christie trapped a bunch of people
on a freaking Bridge because he wasn't
endorsed he's a He's a Bully and he's a
horrible human being but I am actually
glad to have him up on that stage saying
what he's saying when people from Fox
News and whatever are watching because I
do believe he can reach some people that
you and I can't reach well I'll tell you
if you want to talk about Chris Christie
for a second um I actually and I told
the audience this the other day and they
were kind of mad at me because they're
like don't give them any ideas I'm like
look no idea that I say is MAA gonna
take and run with it no [__] way
that's not gonna happen they're going to
think that I'm the dumbest person on the
planet for saying this stuff trust me
but it uh uh but I watch
the clips of Chris Christie absolutely
destroyed which is Key by the way you
watch the clips the way I did because no
I'm not gonna watch eth amendment
protects us while we're talking about
amendments from cruel and unusual
punishment watching that Republican
you'd have to pulled Like Clockwork
Orange [__] on me with my like that to
get me to watch but I watch the clips do
and he watching him kicking VC Ras
Swami's ass is one of the most shoten
fruit filled experiences that you can
have so I'll tell you yesterday I showed
that clip and my take on it is and and a
lot of people didn't like that I was
saying this out loud but it is the real
raw truth um if Maga and the Republicans
plucked their head out of their ass like
they like they plucked it out of their
ass and they decided that Chris Christie
could be the nominee Chris Christie
would beat Joe Biden and the reason why
he would beat Joe Biden is because of
the performance that he had against VC
ramaswami poop Matt Ron and how how he
[__] co-opted Nikki Haley's voters to
come to his side he's very Master he's a
master say you can say whatever you want
he wanted he found a way that first turn
you know in the beginning there to win
in you know to win in Democratic New
Jersey which no Republican has done for
governor for a while besides him he is
that what he did there I mean again and
I'll criticize him to the end what an
evil he's a scumbag Chris a [__]
scumbag was a master stroke to get in
and defend Nikki Haley to try to win
some of her people and sound more
moderate and then wedge some of them
away and then go after ramaswami he
extreme he in in a way he's making it
like Nikki Haley can't defend herself
I'll defend her and Ras Swami is a piece
of crap and he's POS positioning himself
right in the middle there and I wouldn't
say I wouldn't go so far to you say that
because I think if the economic record
comes out it can help Biden I wouldn't
go so far as to say he would definitely
beat him but I would be really scared of
Chris chis their nominee and I would
actually say I would probably give him
the advantage over Biden I agree I I I
definitely I definitely especially in
the middle of the country and the places
like we're from
um they love this tough guy thing even
though it doesn't make a lot of sense
they love the tough guy thing that's
what they love about Trump and I I want
to point out that I I do not discourage
desent here on the show that is why I
welcome the argument between me and you
about how we stand for Liz with what Liz
jany and how she's doing it but uh
Snowden says here I don't agree with
Tony and I think she's not agreeing
because of uh Chris Christie and I'm not
saying it because that's what I want
what I'm saying is is that what what you
have to understand about MAA and where
they're at and the cult and Republican
party is they are standing there looking
at someone who could beat Biden and
they're choosing the person that will
definitely lose to Biden yep and and and
it's because of their delusion and their
cognitive dissonance and folks that's
what my optimism is and I I tell they I
mean again optimistic about 2024 yeah I
am too they can't think any other way
and already uh abortion rights has moved
the dial by seven points on average
District or you got the on Democracy
absolutely the economy at some point the
people are feeling it more and more so
it's less important for the media to
report it but at some point when we have
record-breaking month after
record-breaking month we have this
amazing economy it's gonna have to be
covered and I really do think at that
point we're in great shape and I even
think we're in great shape to beat those
two [__] aliens you know Ted Cruz and
Rick Scott their scumbags because I do
think a seven-point shift if it happens
in Florida and Texas some other states
not good enough can it is it enough to
beat Holly in your state I'm not sure I
hope it is but you know it depends on
the candidate who the candidate is here
in Missouri protect most of our
candidates and to beat Rick Scott and to
beat Ted Cruz and so yes I've got I I've
got optimism about this stuff going
forward too and thankfully you are right
they are too crazy they will not pick
the one guy who I think would have the
by far the best shot at winning um the
one place I will disagree with you is
when you say that you allow descent on
the show I just want to warn everybody
like you see me sitting here right now
but I I'm you could have a body double
here in two weeks like with Federman and
what happens is Tony you know sent me
down to to GMO and I'm locked down there
and you just don't know it there's like
there's a Federman type body double of
Cliff Sher City so don't
fall that vual bastard isna it is I'm
telling you I'm gonna I'm GNA replace
Cliff with a and have the the cliff who
doesn't desent here on the show and send
the other that's true yeah um Scotti
here points out because I said [__] you
pay me earlier he points out that it's
from Good Fellas so I think he wants um
it is from good it is from Good Fellas
and I think he wants the sound effect I
think is what he's wanting yeah we I
just actually watched that with one of
my kids this again I watched it again
I've seen it a million times but this
past weekend you know yeah with with
it's it's hey you got a problem [__] you
pay me right [__] you pay me [__] you
pay
well that's we we
actually uh what's his name Paul Cino
yeah yeah yeah it's it's Paulie is the
is the so so the scene the scene from
Goodfellas is um a restaurant owner has
a problem with with Nikki which is Joe
pes's character coming in and bullying
him and running off a tab so he goes to
the mob boss uh which is over
Nikki Joe pes's character and he uses
Henry which is Ray leota's
get along with everybody yeah and he
gets he gets Paulie the mob boss to come
in with him and be in business with him
in the restaurant so he can provide
protection to him and this is how the
shoot him he's like well that wouldn't
be the worst idea right stares Down's
like okay just kidding I'm sorry but you
know he's being tough on me I mean right
it's a perfect it's a perfect
description and every time I I look at
someone like Bill bar or John Bolton um
or any of these people who hold these
books and hold this information uh to
write a book and to profit off the
demise of our democracy I always think
of that scene and I always think of [__]
you pay me [__] oh you oh oh you ain't
got the money who gives a [__] [__] you
pay me like it always reminds me of I
see think of that absolutely because
that's that's what they're that's what
they're looking for yeah that's that's
what they're that's what they're looking
for um uh when it comes when it comes to
that let me see if I can find the I
actually we actually have the sound
effects so far off the Trump bandwagon
when it becomes a of they're smart
enough to understand the legal Jeopardy
he's in and they want to distance
themselves as much as possible it's [__]
you pay me and also uh [__] you don't
put me in prison right of a combo of of
things going on there that is true that
is true um Cliff I love having you on
and I'm glad we got to talk about
because I wanted to talk about
um grandpa poopy pants is um admitting
that that we are a democracy even though
he he kind of did it weirdly he did
admit that we are and that he undermine
it that's is really is really happy
about that see I can talk about myself
in the third person just like Donald J
Trump can are you president though are
you president Cliff Sher is it president
Cliff Sher is really I mean you know
everyone who's not a president says
they're a president so why not you're
president kli Shor president Cliff sheer
tell me Tell the audience where they can
find president Cliff sheer and all his
authoritarian content all of my fascism
you can
find the place that I'm trying to build
up the most is the
YouTube C I have to say one more thing
quickly that's C Shor um I got banned
I'm still in Twitter at Cliff Sher but I
got banned for 12 hours last night
because when when Mike Johnson referred
to himself as Moses um I went on and I
said well maybe he should try climbing
on a boat going to the middle of the red
sea diving in and seeing if the water
parts and they decided I was encouraging
suicide because of that even though like
who's who's the dangerous one here the
guy who thinks he's Moses or me making a
stupid biblical joke but I am still
there even though I hate Elon in the
whole place but you know it's still
moves the conversation so you can find
me Cliff Shor on Twitter and if you go
on threads it's Cliff dor I don't know
why I'm Different everywhere because I'm
an idiot but C Shor which is YouTube
that's the one that's the most important
one because that's the one we're really
trying to grow as you're trying to grow
this thing yeah absolutely well I mean
we're all we're all trying to grow as we
uh as we fight the the day one dict
taster I mean dictator who apparently
knows where democracy but he definitely
wants to undermine it so Cliff thanks
for joining us I'm also glad that we got
to talk about the uh University of
Pennsylvania and the controversy there I
think that's important issue to to show
that because these students that are
losing their scholarships are now
whining and crying about the
consequences of their freedom of speech
and I want them to understand I want
everyone to understand that they had the
right to speak they spoke and now
they're facing the
consequences
but consequences from private absolutely
absolutely thanks thanks for coming
again my friend we'll see you in a
couple weeks everyone stick around we'll
be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the Capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy P's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product paron blanket I've got
you covered paron blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup part and blanket will
protect you to too pardon blanket is
made of a sort of soft fleece and a
layer of sheep's wool and they're 100%
made in the USA don't delay and get your
pardon blanket today for just
$99.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast [__] you pay me
that
is it's a
great
[Music]
great that Bonet of the week coming
up end of the week guy with the last
name Sanchez should be here very soon
and see if I can get tabs on him a
little bit thanks Cliff jeor for coming
on again he couldn't make it yesterday
so he decided to come on today which uh
was perfect because these issues that I
wanted to talk about and uh again I want
to let the audience know that I do
welcome descent on this and you notice
that me and Cliff did not fully agree on
Liz jany as you all don't always agree
with me on everything and that's okay
the important thing is that we have a
conversation and that the conversation
moves the narrative forward that's the
whole point because I believe as Cliff
he kind of agreed with what I was saying
that her First Amendment right to use
her freedom of speech to speak out
against Trump and the Republicans would
be more effective uh if she would
actually do what she should do which is
tell the truth she should tell the truth
about it I feel like she's still lying
about it actually I don't feel like I
know she's lying about it and that's
just just how it is and the whole book
to her thing the [__] you pay me [__] I
will not lose my stance on that because
um I'm just just not I'm just not in the
uh in the mood um for someone to profit
off the demise of our democracy because
it's you know good for them in the
moment and it appears they're for
democracy even though they're profiting
off the demise of the democracy and the
truth of the matter is is that Liz
Cheney 100% is responsible for Donald
Trump and she could have stood in his
way long before she did when she knew
who he was long before that so it is um
it is very very very important and we do
that um so so and I think I think if she
did do that thing which is admit that
she was part of the problem um I believe
that she would she would U her her her
her words would not fall on deaf ears
because I don't want it to not fall on
deaf ears right that's what I'm saying
is I want her speech to help not to
hurt and that's and that's why it's and
that's why it's um so important to move
that conversation in that
direction and by having the conversation
inside of our little Echo chamber or our
umbrella make sure because Liz Cheney
wants to be part of our Coalition right
she wants to be part of the
pro-democracy Coalition even though she
doesn't really believe in the Democracy
that we believe in she doesn't she
doesn't believe in that she doesn't want
the people to have all people to have
the Liberty that we want them to have
the pro democracy Coalition as a as a
majority whole she doesn't want that
that's not who she is so she'll never be
part of our Coalition because of that
she can't be part of our Coalition but
she wants to help our Coalition defeat
Donald Trump so she doesn't want to be
part of our Coalition she's not part of
our Coalition she just wants to make
sure that we defeat her enemy that's
important
that's very
important and in that in that reality
that you know that she is wanting us the
pro-democracy Coalition even though she
knows she'll never be in the Pro
democracy Coalition she wants to use our
coalition to defeat her enemy and that's
how she's seeing it that's the prism
she's looking through and that's why
she's not doing what she should
doy coalition to tell America hey it was
me did this it was this stuff that I did
that caused this because either a she
doesn't really believe that which is
ridiculous that she doesn't know that
she's responsible partly for
this right
but if she doesn't know which if she
doesn't know that she was part of this
that makes it even more disingenuous I
think so a lot of people are talking
about the Lincoln project and comparing
the same thing in Lincoln project a a
lot of Lincoln project did and a lot of
Lincoln project people I mean um Naomi
says here George Conway George Conway
was at Donald Trump's um when he when he
won he had a Maga hat on the 91 in 2016
I don't know if you know that George
Conway was
there at the at the acceptance speech at
the victory speech of Donald Trump in
2016 with a Maga hat on and they've
since admitted that you know that they
might have been of the problem but I
mean even the Lincoln project and the
founders of the Lincoln project like
like Steve Schmidt Steve Schmidt is the
is the architect behind Dean
Phillips yes that's the truth now if you
want to know the truth about Dean
Phillips it I
mean it kind of feels
like to me I mean maybe I'm off my
rocker here but it feels
like I can smell is what maybe what I
should say I can smell the signed copy
of Haron hitter's
minec uh in the uh Dean Phillips
campaign um here here's Dean Phillips um
on Forbes I don't I don't know Forbes
has a channel now or something I guess
it's a YouTube channel he can't he can't
get on network television because he's
too much of a [__] joke I guess and
Steve Schmidt doesn't really promote him
very well yeah Steve Steve Schmidt and
um a lot of people are pointing out that
he got kicked um he's not part of the
Lincoln project any longer but he was a
founding member
folks this this is this is what I I'm
trying to tell you about some of these
people like Liz Cheney Adam kininger
Mitt Romney Steve Schmidt trying to tell
you about them I'm trying to give you an
idea I'm trying to give you an idea that
yes Steve Schmidt was a founder of the
Lincoln project and Lincoln project does
good work right now against Donald Trump
but when Donald Trump's gone then what
will they
do I mean now that now that Steve
Schmidt no longer has the platform of
the Lincoln project to speak out against
Trump what has he
done
H I'm trying I'm trying to give you re
realistic reality and expectations here
Trump is not going to be around forever
folks I know a lot of people in the
liberal media and a lot of people on the
left um profit and and and actually have
a huge platform because of trump but
he's not going to last forever and a lot
of these people out there who that's all
they can talk about like that's their
only personality treat when they're not
when they're not focusing in on the
problem the problem is the fascism not
not Trump trump is not the [__] the
dis he's not the disease he's the
symptom
okay he's the [__] symptom of the
disease and and people like the Lincoln
project and Steve Schmidt and some
others out there and other groups that
are more liberal than the Lincoln
project treat him as if he is the
disease he is not the
disease he is the symptom of the disease
that's why I try to show you the [__]
symptom I try to show you the disease
not the
symptom I try to show you all kind of
Clips on this show of why it is so
important that we fight fascism in this
country now again he's the he's
metastasized and we don't need to have
fascism metastasized into
authoritarianism or have a [__] dict
taster in this
country but there's some people out
there that would happily [__] fight
against democracy and Dean Phillips is
one of them Dean Phillips is a Democrat
but he's he's no he's no longer part of
the pro democracy Coalition as far as
I'm concerned neither is Steve
Schmidt and and Liz Cheney and Adam KCK
kinsinger were never proud of the
pro-democracy Coalition nor will they
will nor will they ever be because of
their stance and their
views that's just the [__] facts it's
okay that they're not part of the
[__] pro-democracy Coalition and it's
okay that they try to co-opt our help
into rebranding themselves and to try to
defeat their enemy I'm willing to be I'm
willing to be the the reason why we
defeat Trump the pro-democracy Coalition
I am willing to be the reason why we
defeat Trump in
2024 I'm that that's [__] yeah that's
what I
want but this idea that it's Liz Cheney
that's somehow the [__] the reason
that's [__] it is US folks It Is Us
it's us that's why that's why I I
knocked on Joe Scarboro when he acted
like it was our courts that saved our
democracy in 2020 the courts didn't save
our [__] democracy the courts just
[__] told the truth about how we
saved our democracy we did the work we
got out and voted the pro-democracy
Coalition saved this [__] nation in
2020 we got to get our [__] heads on
straight and look at this thing through
the correct lens it's
important it's
important and Dean Phillips here is no
member of the pro democracy Coalition he
may have been at one time but we need to
kick him out on his ass and never invite
him back [__] Dean Phillips [__] him at
same way with
tyt same way with tyt same way with
Chris Cuomo what he said on PE PE peanut
butter podcast or whatever the [__] that
[__] is I don't know some stupid [__]
podcast and a bunch of right-wingers
going Chris Cuomo went on and said that
that Trump wouldn't be any more threat
to American democracy than Joe Biden is
give me a [__] break folks Joe Biden
is not out there in front of a camera
saying that he wants to be a dictator
for one
day he's not saying that [__] and if he
did say that [__] godamn the [__]
right-wing media would melt down they
would [__] melt
down me a break Dean Phillips is no
friend to democracy [__] Dean Phillips
let's listen to him you said that you
know voters here are disenfranchised by
the whole um you know calendar that we
saw play out with the DNC I mean given
all that and given what you've said
about the president do you do you think
that the president is a threat to
democracy
yes because if he wasn't he would say
something about what happened in Florida
last week and if he wasn't he would do
something about what happened in New
Hampshire how can you be the president
president of the United States
condemning the former president who is
clearly a dangerous man and do what he
did in New Hampshire and allow what's
happening in Florida how I mean I don't
quite understand so Dean Phillips wants
Joe Biden to be an authoritarian dict
taster I guess and just you
know sign something and it's all gone
Dean Phillips is a [__] Indian this
same stupid [__] I've been warning you
about with tyt and some of the this
[__] [__] on the left about how
slow walked authoritarianism folks it
doesn't matter where the authoritarian
comes from the left or the right and we
should not [__] support or prop up
any authoritarianism anywhere [__] them
I mean unless it's here on this show and
then I'll I'll be an authoritarian here
um but I'll invite this guy on I mean we
can have this guy on we we we'll have
this guy on this guy this guy has some
dissent sometimes but we agree most time
Gabe Sanchez the guy with the last name
Sanchez here on the show it must be time
for bonehead of the week I guess is that
what is excuse me excuse me very rude
okay very rude time for bone head of the
week oh bone head of the week are you
great AUD in your mouth right now yeah
well it's actually a Halls oh get out of
here can you tell well I can I can smell
the Menthol from here yeah so here's the
thing is like um I start the show and
I'm good because what I do and this is
my secret U for the last couple weeks is
I take Dayquil right before the show and
it kind of gets me all hopped up but
it's got that cough medicine in it to
keep me from from getting into a
coughing fit because I'm fine with the
coughing as long as I'm not like yelling
and screaming and talking the problem is
to do the show I I kind of gotta do some
of that so yeah so I get to where the
first 30 minutes is okay but I get into
the 45 minute Mark and that top of that
first hour and I'm starting to
really kind of feel that you got you got
to double down man you gota so I gotta
pop the halls in the meantime to kind of
stay off any coughing fits that's why
I'm glad to have Cliff because then I
can mute my mic and cough and he's
talking and then I'm glad to have you on
the show because now I can have a
coughing fit without anyone hearing
while you're talking and there's not a
break in the show because you know you
know this there's one thing that makes
me more frustrated anything uh with this
show is I don't like any breaks any I
talk
the full two like the whole thing every
single second there's no there's no
pause there's no break that kind of that
irritates me when it happens but I'm
glad to have you here on the show how's
the car situation going I wasn't able to
watch the other day H how's it uh it's
so basically for people who are
wondering uh car was stolen a little
over three weeks
ago uh I've basically checked in every
week with the police and now it's at a
point where the um
the insurance is like yeah we're not
gonna We're not gonna find it
so car is gone your car is gone it's
gone which [__] sucks around the
holidays um and so I don't so so let me
ask you would
you um and and this is a game maybe we
could play would you rather would you
rather have your old car back or pick
out a new car would you
rather uh I'd
probably because we're at that point at
this point I mean like yeah yeah I'd
probably go for a new car and the only
reason I say that is because I don't
know what was done inside that car oh
and I I was I don't know if it was you
or was someone else was having a
conversation with and when I say new car
like I'm fine with the used cars too
that's not a problem just having a new
car for you is what I mean a different
car a new car for me would be great that
would be ideal now originally like if it
was in the first few days I was like man
I just want my car back and I'll get it
fixed up and whatnot but at this point
point it's been gone for so long that
I'm afraid of what was done in the car
and I'll always have that in the back of
my mind be like oh God wa wait so so you
talking like like someone had sex in the
car or what what's the anything people I
mean people could [__] in the car have
sex in the car they could smoke meth in
the car like there's anything you know
anything you could think of wait wait
wait wait hang on hang on hang on a
second so I want to put these on scales
like what's the worst so where does
[__] in the car sex in the car meth
in the car where do they fall like one
to three wor is like the worst okay so
someone [__] in the car yeah someone
[__] in the car that's the worst then I
would say someone have sex but like if
someone had sex in the car it's like oh
okay like how messy was it you know
because that also plays a role in it
yeah because it could be like a quickie
type situation yeah it could be like
whatever it could be like real hot and
heavy messy and the [__] all over the
place right then it would go into like
somebody doing illicit drugs
okay that's like the least of my worries
I'm just saying what is it about the
elicit drugs is it the fact that they
did it in the car or like they left
their crack pipe in the car it's just
that they didn't do without they didn't
invite me to do it oh I see I see so so
they didn't get permission number one
and you weren't invited to the fu yeah I
didn't get I didn't get like a save the
date or an RSVP kind of thing you know
they did it it's like if you're gonna if
you're gonna you know pop that
cherry when it comes to drugs oh [__]
you let me know but it's so you're
saying you're saying if if if the person
out there that stole your cars listening
that if they did want to do meth in your
stolen
car Gabe would be okay with you stealing
the car as long as you invited him to
the crack smoking party as long as he
could go smoke crack in his old car with
you that would be perfectly fine I'm I'm
just saying if you're gonna do it at
least invite the owner into it you know
but when it comes to the worst I'd have
to say [__] because it's just one of
those things where it's like you smell
it and you just know exactly what's
going like it's out there go back from
and as much as I could get that car
detailed because I've also been in cars
where someone has I took an Uber one
time and they go like oh yeah I had a
drunk person they were in the car and
they threw up in the back seat and I had
to go get it detailed and I got it
detailed twice and in the car you could
still smell it like it was in it was in
the fibers and I was like oh and had the
window down I was like I can't do this
right now so if that
happened then shit's you know right next
to it in terms of like what I could
imagine would still be it's still in the
crack somewhere it's still in the
fiber like I can still smell it you know
so that would be my only fear is that
driving around smelling it and then
knowing what they did somebody somebody
mentioned Brandon mentioned bed bugs
that would also be bad but you know
that's easy you can treat with heat in
Steam and you can you can totally get
rid of but when it comes to George
Santos stealing my car and making cameos
out of them that's something you can't
go back from you can't come back from
that you know what we should do we
should go to Bone end of the week and
we're just gonna do a
hard hard transition here there we go
bone end of the week because we got to
get to it so we got we got three good
Bon heads but let's play the music
because everyone loves the little jingle
I love it Bonet of the
[Music]
[Applause]
week
head of the week Bon head of the week so
we got some uh three really good Bon
heads this week
yeah Jim comr pile we got V radama
dingdong and we've got we got Tom two
branches tuberville uhhuh as the
boneheads of the week proper Bon heads
of the week I think I mean I think they
are don't you yeah I think they're
pretty appropriate Bon heads I mean
they're always Bon heads but this week
definitely excuse me if I have to mute
my mic but um so where where shall where
shall we start do you want to start with
um Tommy tuberville because that one's
pretty easy to slam dun yeah that one I
think there's I can find the clip but
there's a clip Tommy Tu he's walking
back I'll look for it while while you're
describing go ahead and so basically
we've gone what 10 months now with Tommy
Tommy tuberville saying that he's not
okay with military paying for
expenses in in specifically in states
where abortion is legal for members of
the military to do
that and he has spent this whole time
being like I don't like this I don't
support it well I don't give a [__]
man your job which is also crazy to
think about that one person can hold up
a whole nomination process of hundreds
of
people that either need to that could
get a better pay get a better position
like if we're really America first then
Tommy tuberville is one of the many
members of the Republican Party who are
anti anti American or America's second
third 50th on the
list so they came to basically a
conclusion where Tommy Tu or tuberville
was like oh well you know what they
didn't get what they wanted we didn't
get what I wanted and so it is what it
is which basically means that we've come
through 10 upwards of 11 months of him
stalling the nomination process just for
the very end of this to be like well it
is what it is they didn't get it we
didn't get what we wanted and now it's
just a waste of
time well here's the clip here's the
clip of H Tommy Tommy Tu branches
tuberville um being by the way as you
pointed out before lives in Florida not
in
Alabama well I mean he is he's not only
a two brancher he's a carpet bagger too
but apparently he's a Bonafide loser but
he doesn't know how to admit that he
lost that you didn't achieve exactly
what you set out to do that the policy
is still in place yeah yeah I it was
pretty much a draw I mean they didn't
get what they wanted we didn't get what
we wanted and you know they just when
they when you change the rules it's hard
to it's hard to win and so they change
the N NDA rules we didn't get to fight
for it to leave it in Senate and so just
unfortunate American people didn't get a
voice do you mind just stating what you
said off camera real quick just what's
going to happen what just happened yeah
just again well we're going I'm
releasing everybody I still got a hold
on I think 11 fourstar generals
everybody else is completely released
from me now somebody else might I think
some there a few other people got holds
on one or two or three people but other
than that it's
over so it's over but it was a draw it
was a draw it was a draw I mean they
didn't get what they wanted I didn't get
what I wanted so you know what Tit for
Tat it's a draw it it's a Cats game cat
scratch right this this football
government stuff look government
government's like football and the
football's like government and when you
when you have draw in the football see
no one really wins and and and and and
and and and the football is like the
government because the because the
football and the government are kind of
they're difficult thing see
see the thing here
that uh you know never ceases to amaze
me is that somebody like Tommy tville is
like well you know uh I got a hold on a
couple fourstar generals you know
someone else got a couple people you
know in their fantasy team that they're
trying to draft and upscale here to uh
to nominate but uh uh yeah I released
everyone which by the way were hundreds
of people and it's not just it's a
domino effect it's not just those people
who are nominated but also was putting a
hold on anyone else who was potentially
going for a nomination to those
positions that would need to be filled
from those people who are actually
getting nominated to a higher ranking
position so the idea was like man I I
released you know I got a hold on a
couple people you know I own them I own
them they're mine uh but everyone else I
I released I put on I put on the free
agent waiver uh how do we say here on
the football team but uh at the end of
the day it's draw and uh cat scratch
fever uh it's see what we did we got
down to fourth down we got down four and
we punted the ball but that doesn't mean
that we gave up the ball it just means
that we're going to get the ball back in
the third quarter and then when the
third quarter
[Laughter]
oh my God all right let's move on Tommy
two branches definitely is a [__]
bonehead but he has lost his bid in the
Senate to damage our national security
uh there's someone else that wants to
damage our national security with a
bunch of Putin's lives which is VC radad
dingdong Gabe Sanchez he's a good friend
my name
correctly no no it's Rama damama
dingdong
I'm not sure exactly why you wanted to
have him on Bon of the week I think I
suggested him probably yeah you send the
text you sent me two of them well I but
I mean I was spot on with him right yeah
yeah of course on with those too now you
chose you chose the last one there but
here's here's VC getting absolutely
trash by Chris Christie and I'm no Chris
Christie fan but I'm all for Chris
Christie doing this to VC rad damaad
dingdong so let's see how uh Chris
Christie destroys rad damad dingdong
here okay
you you do every debate you go out on
the stump and you say something all of
us see it on video we confront you on
the debate stage you say you didn't say
it and then you back away and I want to
say I'm not done yet now
[Applause]
look this is the fourth debate the
fourth debate that you be voted in the
first 20 minutes as the most obnoxious
blo hard in
America so I mean I'm going to play more
of it because I can't help but love when
Chris Christie absolutely tears apart
radama dingdong I can't I can't but love
it I mean how could you not like I I
don't like Chris Christie but I love the
infighting please give us more material
and I said this yesterday on my show I
said please do not stop continue to give
us material that we can make ads out of
commercials out of that we can play on
nonstop repeat 247 on any station that
will have us and any place that will
Quote us you make sure that you play
that as many times you can to actually
show because there's also another part
of this later on which I don't know if
you show the Chris Christy comment uh he
was asked a question by
um uh by CNN and it was is there some
sort of agreement or partnership that
you have with Nikki Haley and he's like
no I don't have a partn ship but here's
the thing they do have a partnership
it's not vote they're not going to go
out and say it obviously because that's
going to cause a lot of people be like
wait wait wait who am I supporting here
but it's the enemy of my enemy is my
friend and they are partner they are
colluding in the background to defend
each other if it means that they can
[__] go after V ramaswami so that's
what it is because V ramaswami we know
is the surrogate he's the proxy he's
Donald Trump's plant right what we've
always known that yeah but watch Chris
Christie tear him apart here because the
one the one part is just CHR Christie
you're speaking to my heart when you
have boil down radama dingdong
[Applause]
here I want to say something else we're
now 25 minutes into this debate and he
has insulted Nikki Haley's basic
intelligence not positions her basic
intelligence she doesn't know regions
she wouldn't be able to find something
on a map that his three-year-old could
fine look if you want to disagree on
issues that's fine and Nikki and I
disagree on some issues but I'll tell
you this I've known her for 12 years
which is longer than he's even started
to vote in a Republican primary oh
that's a sick burn now you're saying
that Nikki Nikki Haley and and Chris
Christie are colluding to to kind of
defend against V radad ding gong but
here's the thing is I believe what Chris
Christie is doing here and and maybe
maybe they are colluding um but he's
tricked Niki Haley into this is that
Chris Christie is trying to welcome uh
Nikki Haley voters to his side because
the fact is is it's a Republican primary
and Nikki Haley isn't gonna win because
she's a woman I mean that's pretty
[__] simple I don't know if people uh
know that that that's the case but it's
obvious that that's the case I I don't I
don't know what World they think we're
living in but she won't be the nominee
because she is a woman she won't make it
to South Carolina she has to make it to
South Carolina she has to win in South
Carolina yeah what Chris Christie is
doing is he is he is inviting her
Coalition her anti-trump coalition to
his side being like well hey if he's
willing to defend Nicki Haley then I'm
willing to support him because I support
Nikki Haley you know I support I support
women too so I'll vote for Chris
Christie like it you know they a't got
it all B no no I mean it you're you're
EX he's an he's a extending an olive
branch to that side to say hey in the
event that Nikki Haley does drop out
which she will she won't win South
Carolina which is her state if you can't
win your own State and you a two-time
governor you're done you're done you're
done but when it comes to the the
rankings of like options it goes Donald
Trump with a
far in in between uh majority he's got
like High 40 low 50% then you've got
Ronda santis who's like high 30 low 40%
then you've got Nikki Haley at like the
teens and then you've got uh Chris
Christie and V ramaswami I think V
robomi might be doing a little bit
better than Chris Christie but they kind
of flipflop and they're like the single
digits less than 10 range so there's no
and I know I know that we say and I
commented this yesterday on my show I
know that we comment on this show and we
say the are Antiquated don't trust them
but when you have huge swings that are
like double digits that big like you you
can't ignore it and we know that the
majority is going to devote that the way
that they are based on these polls
because again they're not slim margins
where it's like oh they could go either
way it's like no that you have to clear
a 30 point gap you want me give you the
evidence you want me give you the
evidence of why I mean you don't have to
really look at the polls but um and you
can look at those numbers but here's the
evidence of why Donald Trump's going to
win in the primary because there was
only one person that qualified for this
debate that was not standing on the
stage and his name is Donald Trump and
he still is beating these people and
that's all you need to know about this
primary that's all you really need to
know but I want to show you something
else you need to know about VC Ryme rad
damama dingdong here is that he will
literally say any kind of [__] thing
he can to get attention he will read off
your Papa's Facebook page and Go full on
balls deep with Russian propaganda here
listen Donald Trump attempted to take on
and if you want somebody who's going to
speak truth to power then vote for
somebody who's going to speak the truth
to you why am I the only person on the
stage at least who can say that January
6 now does look like it was an inside
job that the government lied to us for
20 years about Saudi Arabia's
involvement in 911 that the great
replacement theory is not some Grand
right-wing conspiracy theory but a basic
statement of the democratic party's
platform that the 2020 election was in
indeed stolen by big Tech that the 2016
election the one that Trump won for sure
was also one that was stolen from him by
the National Security establishment that
actually put up the Trump Russia
collusion hes that they knew was false
there's a reason why I'm the only person
stage who can say these things
that's his boots one time and now Monday
quarterbacking and criticizing when it's
convenient he's like vote for Donald
Trump because they were only bootlickers
once I'm a full-time boot licker so vote
for Donald Trump I I mean V rad damama
dingdong is what I mean pronounce my
name
correctly I will not pronounce your name
correctly I will not I've got a uh I've
got a what was that that I'm gonna film
after this after we film this and um
it's about it's about V ramaswami and
it's about how you know it's like I'm
glad that a lot of people are
coming wakening up you know uh and
coming to the realization that re
ramaswami is you know a stake oyal
salesman he's
not qualified he's a fraud he's a liar
he's a thief all these things and this
this debate was a great example but it
also shows you how far he's come from
the other side now obviously he was
libertarian before and he's Republican
now but in September of 2022 you have to
remember that the guy literally wrote a
book about people playing victim and and
the victimhood mentality and in that
book he has a section where he talks
about Donald Trump he talks about
Republicans he talks about a precedent
that has been created by Donald Trump
and Republicans who are unwilling to
accept any result that is not a win in
their column if they lose they cry foul
and they say that we will deny and deny
deny the election in that book he talks
about January 6th how it wasn't an
inside job how it was was uh terrible
for our democracy he talks about how
Donald Trump is a sore loser uh he goes
into other details but it's crazy to see
not crazy but when you realize that
there's someone behind the
scenes pulling the strings and maybe
feeding you
money like Donald Trump then you
understand how someone could make a
complete 180 turn on making claims like
that that's in a book to then going on
stage and debating and saying oh well
January 6 was an inside job 911 was an
inside job the election was stolen
because of
machines it's crazy it's crazy but also
when you realize that there is someone
behind the scenes like Donald Trump who
is trying to put up v ramaswami as a
shield to fend off attacks but then also
via proxy or surrogate attack those
people for him because he doesn't have
to do it all he has to do is rru it
online that's it well you know speaking
of people who change their tune when the
strings aren't being pulled by Trump U
behind the scenes I want to bring up the
alpha cck of the week for soon to be
former yeah former representative former
speaker Kevin McCarthy now as everyone
knows as I predicted Kevin McCarthy
would would resign his seat uh in
Congress eventually that he would not
rerun but he's but he told us he wasn't
going to quit right well I he he is a
cuck so he would he would do these
things but I'll tell you there is a clip
um of Kevin McCarthy saying the truth
out loud which is [__] hilarious not
even the only time he said that too
right this is [__] hilarious um which
is gonna lead me to the dishonorable
mention uh here to a clip that he was
saying in a private party um now you got
to remember these [__] idiots say
this [__] in private party was that a
private party I think that's well it was
an Oxford student spe or oord yeah yeah
that's what it is but you got to
remember you got to remember these Bone
Heads don't really know the internet
right Kevin but then he went but then he
went to the New York Times uh book
Summit and he said the same thing there
right well and and this is this is the
retribution that Kevin McCarthy is going
to take on Donald trumpan he's tortous
yes because Donald Trump was the one who
Who removed him as speaker um Kevin
McCarthy knows that that's how it
happened he was removed from speaker to
to do his bare minimum responsibility
with which was to keep government open
and he's removed for that even though
Kevin McCarthy understood that that
would help the party not hurt the party
but you know yeah and you you think that
for a guy that fed the man food right
well when he was hungry and depressed
right yeah that you would think yeah
that Donald Trump wouldn't stab the guy
in the back but then Donald Trump so
yeah well here's what Kevin McCarthy
says about his party versus the
Democratic party listen to see if you
can spot truth out loud that most
Republicans all of them wouldn't want
you to hear and when you look at the
Democrats they actually look like
America when I look at my party we look
like the most restrictive Country Club
in America I I gotta tell you I don't
even know if this is honestly I don't
know if this is real if this is AI and I
haven't done that in a while but I'm I I
I let me play it for you again because I
just are you hearing laughter at first
glance I can't say that this guy would
say this [__] but listen again and when
I look at the Democrats they actually
look like America when I look at my
party we look like the most restrictive
Country Club in
America I mean sometimes the truth is
there but again I can't tell if this is
real or if this is AI because I would
never I believe it is real uh I 100% the
and and when I first heard it at the the
the book Summit I was like what right
did he say that that's that's what I'm
saying I'm like what the [__]
I saw somebody tweet maybe Brian Tyler
Cohen he might have tweeted that clip
and said the same thing and I was like
wait I just I just saw him say this and
I was like oh he's he's going he's doing
a tour he's saying it everywhere yes
well and and this is U again this is the
retribution that Kevin McCarthy is going
to uh and he's going to start walking
towards what Liz Cheney is saying M
Romney is saying but it's gonna fall on
deaf ears because again until Kevin
McCarthy would take responsibility for
what he did to this country which is
give us trumpism and MAA and support
them and collude with them and just
stand back and capitulate to them as the
speaker of the house then you're you're
you're your words will fall on deaf ears
but it is interesting that of of how
he's saying and what he's saying let me
let me play it one more time just to
clarify for people in the chat this is
real this is this is 100% I know well
it's again I questioned it at first but
I know but I saw I see people in the
chat being like is this real if it's
real we should yes it is 100% real this
is not the first time he said it in the
last week so but you gotta question this
stuff in this day and age um especially
when you hear them say [__] like this
because this is it's interesting how
he's how he's approaching this right
because he's approaching this asn't in
like oh my party sucks but he's saying
my party sucks without saying his party
sex listen I mean he's taking he's
taking the George Santos look like
America when I look at my party we look
like the most restrictive Country Club
in America yeah so he's doing the George
Santos he's just doing it in front of
the Oxford students union as opposed to
a cameo you know what I
mean have you ordered your uh your
personal J no I'm not gonna order a
[__] C come on man you're not gonna
order a cameo to goof on him you got to
you're like you're like raised also
raised theice you're the master of
George Santos of George Sant information
here's the thing I if I get him to say
something he will say it because what
from the videos I've been watching he
just doesn't even care anymore uh just
it's just to pay him to say something
right yeah yeah yeah yeah so I'm curious
and that's what I was always curious
about is like if I tell him to say
something like I stole and killed those
dogs would he say it you know uh who
knows you could get him to say and admit
that he stole your car I mean I could
get him to do that that is a possibility
because if I look at his price right now
wow okay so so he started at
$75 MH then he went up to2 200 then he
went up to 400 then he dropped it down
to 350 then he went back to 400 and now
he's at $500 a video holy [__] well I
bet I bet I bet Kevin McCarthy makes
more money at this speech at the
Oxford's Union society four hours ago
turned out he turned out two videos in
about 10 minutes which is a th000 bucks
he made
in 10 minutes should go locations with
different outfits Santos is the hardest
working man in America that's what he
said that's what somebody commented oh I
see I see I'm just reading I'm reading
through the comments right now there's a
lot of onear reviews too but there's a
lot of I mean George Santos is likely to
get a lot of one-star reviews you know
who else is likely to get a lot of onear
reviews the wiener of the house mikro
Johnson and a lot of people are pointing
out speaking of speaking in private to
people and saying the the quiet part out
loud the Wier of the house Michael
Johnson apparently went and spoke in a
Nazi rally and and really really showed
his support for white supremacist and
white Christian nationalism it's weird
stuff he's a big a big fan of uh of
supposedly believing that he's Moses as
well it's kind of weird you know it's
it's
funny cuz I'm no Bible expert right it's
been a long time what's your question
it's a long time since I picked up a
Bible but my question is in the Bible
because most Christians you know talk
about the gospel of the Bible and I
don't know if people know but the gospel
of the Bible is the first four books um
of the New Testament but where does
Moses appear in that Bible where does he
appear does he appear in the he's an old
testament bro oh oh oh so what you're
what you're saying is that Christians
maybe shouldn't I don't know look to
Moses as their it's not only it's only
look to Moses right like it's it's it's
also you're looking to so there's like
new God which is the new testament which
is like oh man I had a son and I have
empathy for the right that's the god
that [__] the Old Testament is God God
doesn't [__] the New Testament that's
the
god a tyrant Old Testament is I'm going
to flood the world I'm going to burn it
down I'm going to uh make you sacrifice
your children I'm going to make Abraham
take your son up to the Mountaintop and
sacrifice him for me the weird the weird
that's the weird kinky guy and then the
new guy that came in was like oh [__] I
have a son and he changed his ways when
he had a kid he changed his ways exactly
right well but it it is kind of funny
that these white Christian nationalists
you're like we're Christians we're
Christians they talk more about the the
old Tyrant type God than they do the the
new reformed I'm a Daddy now and I
really do think this is what God looks
like when he's when he's when he's
making babies Oh you mean he's fcking
yeah that's that's how God [__] anyways
um speaking of speaking of God [__]
he apparently has [__] this guy's mind
up let's listen to how he Compares
himself to Moses is really
weird
can you hear the
audio is the audio not coming through I
can't hear it [__] hang on hang
on can the a I can't hear you but I
can't hear it can the audience hear the
audio this no audio no audio audio audio
audio audio son of a [__] hang on hang
on what did you do man I don't know let
me let me let me [__] hang on let me
get it refresh here let's see if it it
might be the the the programming it
could be the Deep State too it could be
that we were speaking against God and
Moses and God was like no audio for you
we were speaking ill of the
omnipotent all powerful reigning
unforgivable God I guess so let me let
me uh let me
get there I think it's playing now can
you hear it now no it's the video it
sounds like Texas Paul had the same
problem so you got to find this video
somewhere else dude oh my God what a
bunch of [__] man that's called The Deep
State M Audio bro all right let me I can
hear it I can hear it through my
headphones um but apparently God does
not want us to show how mikro Johnson
the wiener of the house wants to be
Moses or compared to Moses or thinks he
is Moses some [__] you know who else
said he was Moses who
Moses like the guy the actual Moses was
he did he uh uh sorry hold on I just
want to make sure I [__] forgot his
name who played Jesus oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah Henry um no uh [__] this guy's
name I know who you're talking
about a you [__] me I'm not gonna play
this glint
kavel yeah yeah yeah he said he was
Moses and he said Donald Trump was
Jesus wait or no sorry sorry he said he
was Jesus and he said Donald Trump was
Moses so now we're now we're competing I
don't know who Moses is is it is it Mike
Johnson or is it Donald Trump I don't
know I don't know if this is the clip
but we'll try this one let's
see maybe son of a [__] there we
go nope no
audio uh they're working against me here
I'm I swear to God it's
it's deep state it's the Deep State it's
the Deep state is that where it was
working earlier what the [__] here we'll
try to we're try to reshare see if we
can get this going here here here it is
again let's try this let's let's see
audio
um no
audio Jesus Christ so apparently um we
can't share this because God does not
want us
to
it is it is it sounds it sounds like
there's a lot of censorship going on
over at uh
twitter.com might be might be what it is
uh well you know it is what it is here
so tell tell tell the folks um what Mike
Ro Johnson said about Moses while I try
to see if I can fix this [__] on what
what was his what was his words about
Moses because he said he wanted to not
any wanted to be Moses he is Moses right
he compared himself he Compares himself
to Moses because God spoke to him right
because God spoke he heard voices in his
head and then he said that God directed
him to um uh to open up a you know the
path he had the his path to power
through the rolling sea so basically in
a keynote speech at a gathering
Christian nationalist lawmakers on
Tuesday night house Speaker Mike Johnson
compared himself to Moses leading the
GOP conference and America through the
paring of the Red Sea if anyone
remembers that they were boom boom on
their way out of Egypt and Moses part of
the sea right staff Moses uh which
really was a low tide and people were
able to cross that's what the story is
um anyway he addressed the National
Association of Christian lawmakers at
the group's award Gala because you know
they got to award themselves with
participation
trophies uh perhaps unaware of the event
was being recorded again you just got to
assume that everything you do in life is
being recorded I always am a I'm I'm
always whether it's on this show or I
turn the camera off I know somebody's
watching me in this room okay I know so
I gotta be careful what I do so you
don't you don't you don't spank in that
room then no no no that's a I go in the
closet okay uh I'll tell you a secret
not that secret I'll tell you a secret
he said since media is not here thank
you for not allowing the media in
because again
transparency uh censorship is the guy
who wants to blur the faces of the Jan 6
insurrectionist in videos even though he
had to walk that one back Johnson then
revealed that the leadup to the tumult
of Kevin McCarthy losing the Gabel in
the chaotic GOP process of selecting new
speaker had been speaking directly from
God look I'm a southern baptist I don't
want to get too speaky or too spooky on
you he said provoking some laughter from
the attendees but you know the Lord
speaks to your heart the message he
received from God from God Johnson said
was to prepare the Red Sea moment but
for the Republican conference and in the
country at large Johnson said found the
directive confusing but he continued to
seek the counsel of God God's not
talking to you man you're [__] crazy
okay Jesus Christ no one is talking to
you you're talking to yourself you might
have had a psychotic break might want to
go 5150 put yourself in a in an asylum
or something get some treatment make
sure your mind's right maybe get some
medication I know you guys love big
Pharma you
know then he said the Lord began to wake
me up through this three week process in
the middle of the night to speak to me
Johnson insisted now at the time he
continued I assume the Lord is going to
choose a new Moses but because of his
own lesser rank among the gop's
leadership Johnson said he believed the
Braven Le message to be you're gonna be
you're going to allow me to be Aon to
Moses citing the role of the old
testament's prophet's brother to
biblical
sidekick because that's all he is he's a
[__]
sidekick
Moses mes wait wait wait he said so I
waited and waited and at the end the
Lord said now step forward Johnson
regaled the audience with this surprise
of the tapping of Moses figure Johnson
said I'm supposed to be Aaron I'm not
supposed to be a main leading character
he didn't say that part but I said that
uh but that was not the message Jonathan
insisted Rec calling no the Lord said
step
forward he said this [__] Jesus [__]
Christ yeah I don't know if he said that
but he said the other
stuff that dishonorable mention the
wiener of the house Mike Johnson or
should we call him Moses Johnson um from
henceforth because apparently he
believes because voices tell him in his
head now I I gotta tell you like I I'm
gonna vote for Joe Biden because I like
democracy and if it was anything else
like a ham sandwich or whatever I would
vote against autocracy every single time
but I gotta tell
you if Joe Biden was coming out in front
of the camera saying that he heard
voices in his head and then he was
talking back to these voices and he was
having conversation with these voices
about the decisions he was making as a
government official I would be like holy
[__] maybe people are right about Joe
Biden being goddamn psychopath I mean
it's crazy [__] that you're St and he's
like I don't want anyone to record that
I'm talking to people in my head like I
don't want anyone to record that I'm
having conversation with people in my
head don't don't let the the media be
here to record this I will I will call
out and and and and
uh mes make the enemy of a situ I I'll
see a homeless person on the street and
I'll say God that guy's crazy he's crazy
you know he lost his mind he's talking
to
whoever is he talking to maybe maybe he
thinks he's Moses that's right so
Republicans want to go after you know
people on the street and people who
might seem crazy and out of their mind
or whatever but then they themselves are
saying you know I feel like someone on
the street who was crazy be like I'm not
that crazy I'm look I'm crazy but I'm
not that
crazy and that crazy being believing
that you talk to God and there was a
moment in time when I went through
Catholic grade school and I was like
part of a youth group in high school
where I was like Can people really talk
to God priests say they talk to God all
the time and then I'm thinking I was
like well when I hear myself talk I'm
just talking to myself like it's just me
doing a character or a bit inside my
head so the idea that somebody says oh I
spoke to God I'm like maybe you want to
get help I don't know well speaking to
someone who needs to get help we got our
winner James comr pile James comr James
comr pile is our winner of bonehead of
the week and um it's because of his
delusions Gabe Sanchez let me give you a
piece of it you got a lot of people
including here's a tweet from an analyst
that says that these are just uh
payments already reported in the media
for a truck that Joe Biden bought for
his son he says I don't think Froning a
son money for a truck is an impeachable
offense he says another swing and a miss
your response to that that's bull crap
look if if he wanted to send his money
to his son for a truck then send him
money for his truck but he got that
that's what he that's what he did Gabe
Sanchez that's that's what he did you
know what you know what he didn't do
what didn't he do he didn't use a shell
company to handle the transaction wa
wait wait wait is this an LLC cuz you're
talking llc's and I never said LLC and
but iist it's an LLC okay uh guys you
just gota James comr okay you just got
to understand there's plenty of evidence
that Joe Biden did do something illegal
okay you think you think an LLC is is a
shady shell company I mean I me is it I
don't know anymore uh James
comr is a complete
embarrassment to I mean the Republican
party but also just like the state of
democracy as it stands right now um but
James comr there's even a clip uh
there's a clip from this morning
of Peter
duy on the White House lawn
admitting that they J is an idiot that
James's find that I I like I like this
clip here this really shows his
boneheaded and shows how stupid I can't
I can't even believe that Republicans
did the thing that's going to help us
the most as the pro democracy Coalition
and put this guy on the overside
chairmanship um but here it is here's
James comr pile explaining how interest
doesn't work see you can loan people
money if they pay you back then you you
benefited directly from the influence
ping te
because so if you loan someone money and
they pay you back without interest you
totally benefited I don't not sure how I
mean other than like maybe Goodwill I
don't know but um generally Banks don't
survive if they just give out money for
Goodwill they don't charge yeah um
interest on how they make money when you
loan someone money to make money on the
money when you loan it but you know who
am I who am I to say um you know how
interest works you know and also also
when it comes to banking institutions
microloans are way better than huge
massive loans that people get it is true
it is true it is true non-interest loans
in the amount of
$4,100 uh bring in way more profit from
bribes than gazillions of dollars it is
true this is true stuff uh let's find
out the truth that Peter duy comes to
here on the White House lawn on Fox news
this morning the house oversight
committee has been at this for years and
they have so far not been able to
provide any con evidence that Joe Biden
personally profited from his son Hunter
over they are going to try again with
this impeachment inquiry that's set to
start next week do it do it you [__]
idiot step on that rake please please
round two you're gonna embarrass
yourselves because you're G to be
exposed again he says he says the truth
and this is like with the one time I'm
like oh my God I I agreed with [__]
Peter Ducey uh but this I think he's
trying to warn him because because like
like we're warning we're warning like
Republicans and comr pile when we're
like hey you're you're going to fail
here this is so stupid why are you doing
this exercise because he's like we're
gonna have Hunter Biden come in and
testify I'm GNA Ro the penis and Hunter
bid's like okay hold my beer I'll come
in and testify and he's like no Hunter
Biden can't come testify because that
would really [__] us up and then this
morning don't come public don't come in
the public right don't do not come right
do not come right I'm going to come I'm
going to come speaking speaking of
Hunter Biden in coming um when is MAA
GNA come to the conclusion that they
should love Hunter Biden when is James
comr P because I mean I pointed out this
morning that they love tax cheats they
[__] love them man they [__] love
tax cheats they love people with guns
they love people who cheat their taxes
they love hookers they love blow I mean
have you seen the pictures from have you
have you seen the pictures of the
parties from Mar Lago
it looks like Hunter Biden would fit
right on him oh yeah yeah many of the
photos that that that Donald Trump has
taken with some of these women where I'm
like well I mean Kimberly guilfoil's
there helina habba is there I'm not
saying Kimberly gilfoil and helina habba
participate in doing cocaine I'm just
saying they definitely participate in
doing cocaine I mean they're within the
proximity Donald Trump junr have you
seen Don Jr right guys
okay guys ni and I'm not I'm not I'm not
advocating that that people shouldn't do
blow at parties and people shouldn't
hire sex workers and [__] them all night
long I'm not saying that I actually I
I'm a big advocate for sex work is work
and honestly I think we should
decriminalize uh uh doing drugs in this
country but it just seems a little weird
that Maga doesn't have a hard on for for
Hunter Biden at this point but they
can't they can't
scario it's like when you know it's like
the trans Community or someone who's gay
they're like oh God I'm aroused I can't
be aroused oh God their you know their
dick is bigger than mine like whatever
it might be they they have this
inferiority complex um Napoleon syndrome
they have this ability to have the most
fragile Vos call them call the other
thing too
is they call other people snowflakes
right they're like oh man they're just
so sensitive [__] lip turd snowflake
purple hair blue hair this blah blah
blah
blah and what's funny about the and I I
just want to point this out the funny
thing that I I know about or I I want to
acknowledge about them calling other
people snowflakes is that snowflake
comes from Fight Club which is a whole
critique on toxic masculinity so they're
using a term from a movie that is making
fun of those people to then try to use
in an attack against everyone else and
it's just one of these it's just another
thing where you look at the people at
marago you look at the people that are
in Congress in the Senate the Republican
Party each of them are incredibly
sensitive they would they would love to
do this same type of crazy insane fun
party outgoing dangerous whatever might
be that Hunter Biden does behind closed
doors I mean let's just remember Madison
cawthorne cocaine sex orgies okay and
I'm not against cocaine sex ories I'm
not against them I'm not against them
right you do you whatever you know as
long as it's safe and isn't illegal or
whatever sensual right yeah well I mean
cocaine's illegal but it shouldn't be I
mean really honestly it shouldn't be but
they they want it to continue you have
to you have to acknowledge the absurdity
of this party who loves to talk about oh
how sinful Democrats are or how sinful
everyone else is right but then when you
look at them behind closed doors they're
probably having [__] swingers parties
man they're like oh drop the keys in the
bow know we're no one's going I don't
know if you heard about moms for Liberty
but they love they love
a good a good the loudest people have
the most to hide well I accusations are
just confessions I want to give um our
our winner of boneh hand of the week
comr pile a piece of evidence here
because I found it on Fox News this is
definitely going to secure that they're
going to impeach Joe Biden it's a fox
business alert here Gabe Sanchez this is
breaking news and this will be the
evidence that comr pile needs to impeach
Hunter Biden here it is
199,000 jobs added in November
unemployment rate came down to 3.7%
godamn it and Beach Hunter Biden impeach
Hunter Biden that's what all this is is
a [__] distraction is what I'm
pointing out it's not looking great
especially as they're about to go on
holiday they're recess and the last
thing that you hear about when you go to
your family for dinner for employ rate
is down or Christmas or Quanza whatever
whatever holiday you might celebrate
you're going to sit down have dinner and
be like man I'm so happy about that job
support yeah well um there's all the
evidence that you need James comr pile
199 jobs created employ unemployment
rate down to 3.7 impeach Hunter Biden
now impeach him James comr pile the
Bonet of the week game Sanchez let's
give him his
due
[Music]
oh comr pile you are a [__] bonehead
100%
idiot and keep going I hope you keep on
your idiotic oh he's not going to stop
because there's no way he cannot he
cannot stop he has to commit to this bit
in that he has no other opport I mean
like if you look at the accomplishments
or the things that have been passed I
mean again you look at what Kevin
McCarthy has said you look at what
George Sanders has said you look at what
Joe Biden has said they've all said the
same thing the Republican party in this
conference has accomplished little to
none over the last year they've spent
all of their time all of their effort
being like we're going to have a house
oversight committee and the GOP is going
to find the corrupt nature and root it
out and we're going to show that it's
Joe Biden Hunter Biden and the whole
Biden crime family and what have they
shown Tony they show there was a loan
Between Brothers they showed there was a
loan for a car they also revealed there
was another loan Between Brothers that
was between a shell company for land
swapping but that was actually
Republican again it's just one of these
things where Republicans try to claim
there is some crime the Democrats did
when really they're shining a light on
their own crimes their own sins their
own infidelities whatever it might be
well the other thing that they shown the
other thing they shown to me and the
nation is that Hunter Biden knows have a
how to have a good [__] time that's
goddamn right even though he doesn't pay
his taxes he knows how to spend that tax
money on a good [__] time on hookers
and blow this has been bone out of the
week we got a few announcements right
after the chime stick
[Music]
[Applause]
around
of the week that's a shitty transition
but I got it I got It's
Friday I'm having a coughing fit but go
ahead Gabe Sanchez tell us what was that
and what's going on over there on your
YouTube channel tell us what I got some
notes Here I got some notes Here on on
my thing going get it going I got I'm
working I'm I'm I'm finishing up writing
I got a what was that on B being this
well outside of fake but being the Trump
surrogate Trump proxy the Trump plant
but bringing up stuff from the debate in
other moments I'm working on uh Santos
Cameo you know because he's a cboy now
I'm also working on one that's Trump's
Health Comer's lies and there's another
one about Trump and Robert dairo where
he got a little little too sensitive
little couldn't take a joke couldn't
couldn't take some criticism well go
over to I amab sanchez. comom that's I
amab sanchez.
find what was that you can also find him
on YouTube
youtube.com am gab Sanchez follow his
channel what was that what was that
show.com or you just go to patreon.com
gab Sanchez either one works pretty
direct but also you can stay here every
Tuesday [__] Wednesday and Thursday and
you can watch Gabe Sanchez live right
after this show on Tuesday Wednesday and
Thursday for a full hour on what was
that live with Gabe Sanchez also don't
forget to go join the book club on
Discord go to the Tony michaels.com join
the Discord they're doing the book club
sponsor by the library of democracy win
every argument you read this book Gabe
win every argument by Minnie Assan
they're doing this book club in the
Discord right now look at that you got
you got that right there look at that
boom boom boom you gotta get in in the
Discord in the book club go to the Tony
michaels.com while you're at the Tony
michaels.com don't forget to get your
tattoo merch collection that's right
tattoo merch collection uh let me give
you let me give you a little special
promo code here it's 10% off your entire
order you just use the promo code
holiday 10 holiday 10 that's holiday all
caps one Z holiday one Z to get your
tattoo merch off your entire order you
get 10% off until Sunday until the 10th
if you get it in by then if you get your
order in by then you'll should have it
by Christmas if you get your order in by
then so go order your tattoo merch at
theor michaels.com come and find all the
linkies there if you want to support the
show and I appreciate all the support
here at the show and all your support
that you give to Gabe Sanchez on his
channel and his show and I'm so glad
it's Friday have a great weekend bone n
of the week Gabe Sanchez the Tony
Michaels podcast same time same place on
Monday surf sub
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's meor head ass
speaking all right magas I know you're
pissed off so am I let's get the word
out in my link for $100 you can buy this
t-shirt shirt and it says innocent you
know he's innocent get it today wear it
proudly if you want to make flags out of
it do it let's go to the court on
Tuesday with this t-shirt on and let the
world know he is
innocent okay $100 in my link go for it
all right magas I know you're pissed
off